[Music]
well recently I did find out that she
has had an affair uh with a with a woman
her friend how do you go through
something like this and then what what's
the next step when you find out somebody
that you've been with for over 23 years
thrown that all the
[Music]
way what up this is John with the Dr
John delone
show man I'm so glad that you with us
we're talking about mental health
emotional health we're talking about
parenting
schools what's going on at your office
whatever you got going on in your life
when it comes to relationships and your
mental emotional health I got you I'm
going sit with you and hear what's going
on these are real people going through
real things and we're going to figure
out what's the next right move where do
we go from here if you want to be on
this show um I'm a neutral third party I
don't really have a I've got a lot of
biases but I don't know you and so I
don't have decades with your
mother-in-law coming after you I don't
know your husband or your wife I don't
know your kids and so my promise is I'm
gonna sit with you and we're going to
figure out what we can do next if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz
1844 693 3291 it's 1844 693
3291 and leave a message let us know
what's going on and even though Kelly
ain't no Hollow back girl she will give
you a call back and we'll put you on the
show or go to John dooney.com
ask and couple things um quick shout out
to a couple sponsors one Thorn
supplements go to thorne.com thee letter
uone thorne.com
youone pick up 25% off maybe even 35 25%
off everything in the entire shop you
won't find a better deal anywhere and um
that's us hooking you all up because we
love you we're so grateful for you and
don't forget building a non-anxious life
is out there ready for Christmas and the
Christmas deck questions for humans the
relationship ones the ones with your
kids grandparents and kids to save your
holiday season and give youall some
tools into the new year you're listening
to this it's a couple days after
Thanksgiving listen don't Coast for the
rest of the
year get a month head start on your New
Year's resolution start right now right
now start right
now what do you want next year to feel
like who do you want to be next year
start right now making those moves
you're worth it your family's worth it
your kids are worth it your
neighborhood's worth it this country is
worth it make your move go for it let's
go out to uh the UTS to the Salt Lake
City to the SLC talk to Randy what's up
Randy thank you Dr deloney for taking my
call of course man what's up so my wife
and I have been married for over 23
years we've got three adult children one
is married two are off to college and uh
over the last several years I've had
suspicion of of multiple Affairs but she
kept my wife kept telling me Oh it's all
in your head it's in your head well
recently I did find out for as a fact
with proof that she has had an affair
with a with a woman her friend okay and
she has decided to move out and and
abandon us and move out with her new
girlfriend or slash wife okay what do I
I
mean talk about a shock right no kidding
what how do you how do
you how do you go through something like
this and then what what's the next step
when you find out that that that
somebody that you've been with for over
23 years has just thrown that all away
and and not just any throw it away but
throw it away and go live with another
woman yeah I I think the
um I don't want to let
the who um or even what um I don't want
that to make this more complex than it
already is so I don't want you to get
hung up on she's with my best friend
she's with some random guy from work or
she's with another woman I I think
that's a distraction from the core
issue the core issue is your wife said I
don't love you anymore I love somebody
else I'm
out and I think it's easy to find a
bunch of other things I'm going to be
mad at my buddy I'm G to be so angry at
you know dating apps I'm going to be mad
that she's with a woman and now she's
telling me she's gay what I think that's
a distraction from you feeling the
depths of hell that you have been cast
into okay and so I think healing or
you're not at the healing Point yet I
think grieving dealing with the reality
of this is step
one often Almost 100% of the time when I
have this conversation with somebody
somebody of short term somebody of we've
been married for 10 years we've been
married for 20
years often there is the initial shock
and awe and anger and frustration that
happens but often the most
catastrophic
loss is not the person leaving it's that
Randy you knew for a long time something
wasn't right mhm and now all of a sudden
the person you trust less than her is
you lost trust in Randy and it makes it
hard to know what to eat it makes it
hard to know what to time to get out of
bed it makes it hard to know what to say
to your
kids because suddenly the most confident
person you were in the world suddenly
you don't trust that guy
either is that
true uh most of it I I trust myself um I
and I I'm strong enough person to know
okay what it is and I need to take care
of myself and continue if not for myself
for my kids nope for you for taking care
of your kids is taking care of yourself
okay so so taking care of myself but
losing trust in others yes um yeah it's
it's definitely hard to trust anyone at
this point yeah so when she said she's
gone what ises that mean is she filing
for
divorce she yes she she left so I filed
okay um she she decided to yeah she had
her whole family come over along with
her girlfriend and pack up all personal
his stuff um and and took off okay so as
hard as this is right now from this
point forward because of her
declaration this marriage this
partnership this best friend you thought
thought you had now this is a business
transaction okay and as much as you
allow your um and we treat we treat our
business partners
fair I don't want
to I don't want to take advantage of
somebody who buys one of my books I want
my book to be a gift for them in
exchange for their 20 bucks okay so
we're going into a business transaction
doesn't mean that you dishonor her you
try to rip her off I'm going to get the
most money for I don't do that with my
customers and I don't want you to do
that with her and I also don't say ah
you know what you don't have to pay like
I have some some costs in this book
right I wrote it I took a year of my
life to do that away from my friends
away from my family away from other
business opportunities I got paper cost
we've got publishing cost it costs money
it's a business right sure and so we are
now in a business
transaction and I going to tell you this
is awful
I hate it for
you I hate it for you I hate the
conversations you have to have with your
kids hate the conversations you have to
have with your friends everybody's going
to have an
opinion everybody's going to give you
stupid advice and dumb advice well just
it's just and dude at the end of the day
it's you laying in your bed in a quiet
house
heartbroken
right yeah
how the conversations been with your
kids they're they're angry yeah uh to
know that their their mom you know just
left and and not not just left but said
you know I I've got the lawyer and we're
going to destroy you is her words
exactly
yeah what what what is what is her vital
against you why does she suddenly want
to destroy
you because I found out the
truth I don't I don't understand it
sounds like she's getting exactly what
she
wants that's that's my thought too
that's why it's so confusing she's she's
getting everything she wants um and and
but yet because I find out the truth you
know she wanted to live both
lives she wanted to live a double life
you pop the balloon of her little
fantasy where she could have you your
security and your stability and your
financial
resources but she could go have this
loving sexual relationship on the side
and just run a double life right uhuh
yeah Y and I you know I've seen that
with with her web searches you know how
to how to live a double life and good
gosh all this it's like are you kidding
me she didn't even clear a search
history my goodness dude oh her her
search history is is a mess of of I
don't know what I should should say on
the on the
show dude that's just like cheating 101
clear your search history right I mean
jeez well even if you even if you clear
your web searches there there's ways
cover people think we're we're searching
in secret uh people know everybody
that's right so um so for her to do that
I mean her web searches and I've got all
that documented sure uh show that she's
been searching not only just you how to
live a double life but uh how to become
more lesbian yeah how to become how you
know how to address it how to what do
you do with other women uh just on and
on and and kind of really gross uh stuff
and then text messages between the two
of them I've I've seen uh and even even
more gross just so yeah it's it's really
disgusting and so here's what I would
recommend you do
I would this going to sound
crazy you know there's been infidelity
you know your wife looked you in the eye
and Saidi want out you know her family
is with
her and they have
moved the more you go Swan diving into
the details into the sorted photos into
the
whatever the more you're
choosing to go
mad have you hired an attorney
yes great I this is what you pay an
attorney
for every time you think
through I wonder if at this party and I
wonder about this and I wonder about
this other woman and this other guy and
every time you do that you're choosing
misery you've hired an assassin let your
assassin do his or her
job you get about healing and every time
if you do the Cannonball back into the
sewage the sewer water you're choosing
misery don't do that and dude by the way
I know it's
hard also let your kids be angry and you
don't fall into the Trap of talking crap
about their mom
okay that will be very very hard to
do but your kids know in their core that
faults in
all they are half their mom and they are
half their
dad and if you start trashing mom now
there's a reality mom chose to leave Mom
made some hard decisions kids I'm
heartbroken that's not y'all's job to
fix but your old man is really really
sad and confused and
heartbroken they don't need to know
about what was on the computer they
don't need to know about the photos and
the texts and all that
stuff it's okay to say yeah mom mom left
she got a girlfriend and her family
moved her out and I'm heartbroken that's
it's okay but she's a this and I can't
believe that don't do that to those kids
okay you do need to have a space for
that and that's your close male buddies
I'm hoping you've got a couple do you
have
any I I do yeah okay yeah I want you to
make it a priority to meet with them
once a week in person if at all
possible and I want you to preface this
with guys I'm coming up on a hard season
I'm gonna be sad for a while I need you
guys
and I know that sounds awkward and weird
and very unmanly but that's the path
forward
right but if you get together and just
talk crap about your wife or talk crap
about what you found or talk crap about
her family or lawyer talk crap about gay
people if you do that you're choosing to
cannonball into the
sewage that's not grief that is
wallow
yeah the grief is you feeling how
freaking quiet your house is at night
now and putting your hand on your chest
and
weeping or get to talking about your
buddies and once you're anger starts to
subside a little bit you're able to have
sorrow in front of other guys and say
the words I really miss
her and I got to build something new now
I did not see this
coming that's
grief and unfortunately that's the only
path forward where you're going to be
well and healthy and
whole does that make
sense yeah I'd hug you if you're were
here I appreciate it it's it's not it's
just something you don't yeah you you
can't see you don't expect right that's
right that's right you got hit in the
mouth yes
so this is a business transaction I
wouldn't talk to her anymore she chose
to leave I wouldn't send text messages
anymore every message she sends to you I
would just let it go into The Ether you
don't have to deal with um sharing
custody of kids or anything like that
your kids are
grown yeah yeah thank goodness yeah and
so you don't have to deal with that
you're going to want to know what she's
doing you're going to want to know how
she's doing you're going to want to know
all that stuff's normal you spent 25
years with her including dating right
yeah yeah that's a quarter of a century
how old are
you 46 okay you've been with her longer
than you haven't been right yeah yeah
it's going to be hard to breathe once
you stop being so pissed
off and that's right because she took
one of your lungs with
her she took your hands and your legs
cuz y'all were one y'all were a
gang
so you're going to have to learn how to
do everything over
again and I wouldn't wish that on my
worst
enemy because everybody deserves
somebody to come home that they can drop
their shoulders and just be
safe and this my friend I'm being
intentional here this is grief this is
sitting in it the reality of it okay not
getting distracted by all the other
stuff
but moving forward dude I wouldn't go
down the search history anymore you got
what you've given give everything over
to the attorney and move on I wouldn't
go through those text messages again and
again and
again just
wouldn't I wouldn't let anybody talk bad
about my wife I wouldn't let anybody
talk bad about the gay community I
wouldn't let anybody talk it just
doesn't serve any purpose at
all the truth is your wife left you
there may be some truth that when it
comes out she's like I've been telling
you for years this or you are struggling
with why or what whatever and there may
be some truth to some things you need to
work on moving forward in your life
Maybe not maybe you just got sucker
punched on this
one make sure you take care of yourself
sleep when you can but also honor when
you're going to wake up at 2 am for six
months get a have a
book have a video have something to
watch and just honor your body as it's
trying to reconcile how to breathe with
only one lung for a
while you'll grow another one but right
now you just got one cuz she took one
it's going to be hard to walk because
she took one of your legs y'all y'all
were one for a quarter of a
century make sure you eat right when you
can make sure you hang out with your
friends make sure you at least walk
around the neighborhood this would be a
great time to start lifting weights if
and get a trainer if you don't have one
let your lawyer do their
[Music]
job it's a business transaction now I'm
heartbroken for you brother hang on the
line I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non- anxious life I don't
know if you're in the mood for reading
this will be a road map to start
building something back and to honor
your body as it rattles and Shakes as it
figures out what to do
now all go ahead and put on your past on
there too what happens when you life
hits you in the mouth and you got to
figure out what to do next
we love you buddy PA if I can never help
man we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free
all right we are back and we've got a
couple on the phone so let's go to Megan
first what's up
Megan hey is this for real is this
actually Dr Don jalone that I'm talking
to right now no it's my
brother my brother Dan he is oh my
goodness crazy how are
you um I'm amazing right at the moment
I'm on cloud n um I can't even believe
I'm talking to you this is awesome thank
you for having me of course thanks for
calling in all right let's bring in Sam
husband uh I just hit I just hit line
three Sam what's up
hey just sitting in the office taking a
phone call you
know you know you guys sound like letter
Kenny it makes my heart feel so full
right now this is so great okay um so
y'all are not in the same house right
now no no okay so y'all can tell the
truth and not have to like eyeball each
other yes all right so I don't really
even know what this Call's about so uh
Megan you go first and you say what you
want to say say what you need to say and
then Sam you hop in and then we'll go
from
there okay sounds good so first thank
you your Insight and wisdom has been
life-changing in every area of my life
awesome so thank you for that um so Sam
Actually introduced me to your show back
in 2020 um and so I'm just going to
quickly go through my question makes
really no sense without the context so
go for um whoever since I started
listening to your show I've been
listening to every episode to try and
get tidbits about parenting we have four
kids we have a 10-year-old daughter and
three boys that are eight six and three
can I just pause good
God yeah we both come from big families
so we both knew we wanted big families
but I don't think I was fully
prepared I wanted a basset hound forever
and then I got one and the smell alone
was amazing
right oh man okay so anyway so we've
been trying to do a lot of the things
that you've suggested um and we've read
some of the books that You' suggested
too um and then outside of that we
talked to a social worker to try and get
some tools and insight to help our
8-year-old son has ADHD okay um and then
we've also gotten him into some classes
to kind of help him get some tools as
well but despite doing all that there's
still so much fighting and disrespect
our 8-year-old can news some days it
seems like he wants to push back about
absolutely everything um he's also can
be very physically and verbally
aggressive and our six-year-old has
full-blown temper tantrums where he's
yelling and he's stomping and he's
hitting and you know we want our kids to
be open to talk about their feelings we
want them to feel safe but I'm exhausted
and I just feel like I'm a garbage can
um I just feel like some days it's all
four of them are just throwing their
crap at me and I'm just like I I don't
know what to do and so what my question
is what can Sam and I do is this an us
problem is there something that we're
not doing or that we are doing we should
stop or is this just a them
problem all right kind of set me up here
all right so Sam what do you
think well I mean for me the hardest
part is like I grew up in a family very
different from mine um I never ever
would say things to my mother that my
children have said to my wife and it
kind of is very difficult
to you know like not do the things my my
father did to me to my children sure if
you catch my drift right yeah totally
and so I I mean for me it's like okay I
got to do better I know I got to do
better but at the same time you know if
my kids don't listen to me when I talk
nicely to them what am I supposed to do
like like you know I I I'm at a loss for
that too where it's like you know I I I
come home from work and it's like you
you know I I really we we worked at it
pretty good so I I rarely come home and
then the bad guy which is really nice as
a as a dad yeah absolutely but even
still you hear you hear the things and
it's like you did what yeah yeah you
know and and so then you're kind of like
now what am I supposed to even do like I
want to love my kids and I want to like
you and I do and I and I do and it's
like but I don't like when I hear these
stories right you know and so then I'm
kind of at a loss for you know how to
proceed past there yeah so let's
um to answer your question
Megan it's a complicated answer where I
like to start because it can be any
number of things okay where I like to
start
is number one kids absorb tension
they absorb
chaos and so a 10 a eight a six and a
three is by nature chaotic right yes yes
it is so they that's in The Ether
already okay so
expecting
calm versus expecting your kids to lean
and push on every boundary is this real
is this real can I pet this tiger I
wonder if this dog will bite me let's
lick a snake let's like you know like
that's what kids are supposed to do okay
yeah and so often there's a tension
because I have this picture of my kids
all like one doing a puzzle one coloring
and one I don't I don't want those kids
I'll just say it that way right yes I
also I don't want my house like the way
it is right now and there so there's a
gap that Gap is for me the adult okay
that's step one y often I will tell a
mom who's staying at home with four kids
are you homeschooling too or are they
going to school oh goodness no they're
going to
school all right yeah no we we did that
covid and I realized very quickly no no
no we're not that's not a thing in our
house that yes I had a very similar
experience in my house so
um so it's very important that you Mom
do what you have to do during the day
when the kids are gone
to take care of
yourself and that is unfortunately you
got to find some places where you can
move your body you got to find some
places where you have some adult women
friends and that might mean we're going
to get a sitter for the three-year old
or if the three-year-old goes to like a
preschool I don't know what it's what
youall have in Canada but if there's
some sort of preschool thing or a sitter
of some sort um but I have to have these
things built into my life because what
I'm trying to do is is take my water
glass and pour out as much water as I
can before those four kids get home and
start trying to test everything all at
the same time because they're going to
be dumping water into that glass and so
I want it as empty as
possible yeah okay I don't know what
that looks like for y'all that's for you
and Sam to figure out okay um yeah
that's step one we're going to lower the
temperature in the house with what we
can control step two both Sam and Megan
I'm not a fan of this gentle parenting
idea your kids don't get to hit each
other period they don't get to be
disrespectful they don't get to scream
and yell and holler and whatever
okay where I do hold the kids
responsible is I say because you did X
you have
chosen to separate from this team for a
minute and it's usually per year that is
one of the things that we have been
doing is we have changed our language to
be if you are choosing this Behavior you
are choosing whatever the consequences
and then starts the
explosion where it's like okay are you
if you're going to choose to yell at me
you're choosing to go to your room and
then it's like no I'm not going to my
room and it's like they literally have
to pick the child and take them to their
room like because now it's getting to be
like okay now we've asked at things you
you do need to leave the room and cool
down and it's so in some ways it's like
we have been doing that but it in some
ways almost escalates things especially
with um with an 8-year-old or
six-year-old so here's the missing
here's the missing piece there it does
require entry into the room with the
kid yeah and this statement or this
series of
statements I know you your body feels so
big and on fire right
now and you look him in the eye and you
say and these feelings don't make me
scared I know that you don't want to be
feeling this big I know
that and I'm going to be
safe more than anything in the world I
want you right by my side in this
kitchen helping me cook
I want you right at the counter working
on your homework so we can laugh and
tell
jokes but when you have these big
feelings and you choose to
hit you choose to not be in there and we
don't work as a family when you choose
to not be
there right so for an ADHD kid I'll
speak to that one the most terrifying
thing they can experience is
isolation right
and unfortunately the way they show that
terror is to make themselves almost
impossible to be in relationship
with and so I'm G to head directly into
the middle of
that chaos and I'm going to be as calm
as humanly possible what they're
desperate for is are you still going to
love me still going to love me still
going to love me yes I will not abandon
you but you can choose to walk away from
us right so that is easier said than
done when you have three other kids
going a
right I totally get
that but there is a heading into it and
being very clear about I know your body
feels big do either one of you have have
ADHD symptoms or I don't know been
diagnosed with
it yes okay yes that would be me okay
and and I'm on meds for it okay um Sam I
I will will honor my kids and not use
say who I had this conversation with but
I I sat down with one of my kids when
they were very young and said you and I
have very very special
brains we have very special brains that
allow us to feel really
big sometimes feelings that aren't even
real and sometimes those feelings feel
scary and it also allows us to sit with
other people when they're hurting too
which makes us such a gift to our
community and to our families and so
here's what I did I walked
through what I did is I made sure my kid
felt not
alone
and years later after that one single
conversation um and we also came up with
a secret hand signal which is to point
to my
head or to point to my
chest that that child refers back to
that conversation you know I've got big
feelings I know and they don't scare me
at all and I'm so glad that you have
them you cannot talk to your mom like
that right and so there was this pieace
that allowed my kid to see okay he goes
to work every day and gets a
paycheck and also I'm just like
him and also see what I'm saying like it
was the social norming going on inside
the house yeah um also there's things
like Physical Therapy a lot of ADHD kids
need to bang into other
things they they stomp through the house
really hard they they got sensory issues
and sometimes something as simple as
physical therapy can be such a gift to a
kid learning how to oh I don't have to
hit the ground that hard right I don't
have to squeeze my pencil that tight um
and some of those things are are really
helpful y'all may have tried some of
those things what about the
six-year-old the six-year-old does not
um although we're aware of he doesn't
have a lot of the this like similar
things at least that we've noticed with
our eight-year-old and our
eight-year-old like we pretty much
noticed it like early on um it was like
we hit the 2-year-old Tantrums at 18
months with our 8-year-old and it just
never stopped sure Andy think about this
think about this that body feels like
it's on
fire yeah yeah our six-year-old I'm not
sure it's I've noticed I I do wonder if
it's just you know so he's the in the
middle of the three boys mhm and you
know we have our three-year-old who he's
three so you know is a six-year-old a
girl no a boy three boys at the end yeah
our daughter is the oldest okay is she
mean or is she nice she's wonderful
absolutely amazing okay can I tell you
where that can be a
problem yes your kids your other three
boys know
that right they have to know that
they're wonderful too
yes they're just wonderful
different yeah and I mean yeah and again
I feel like again we've been trying like
we've done things like you know the
journal writing the journal and of
course which is hard when the kids are
still learning how they're just they're
just drawing pictures yeah yeah do you
um have you all tried the the weekly
breakfast
together no we haven't done that I that
one's what we have been doing is every
um so there's three days in the week
each kid gets a turn staying up a little
a little bit later not super late but a
little bit later with either Samurai and
we do something like play games or have
a tea party or um whatever the thing is
okay um so that they all get that little
bit and they they look forward to it
every week like it's definitely like a
thing y um and it's been great because
that just seems to work best the hard
part is I also work parttime and I'm a
nurse in a long-term care facility so I
work
evenings um and every other weekend so
it's challenging to sometimes scheduling
wise as well and I mean Sam has to be at
work at like he leaves at 700 so then
it's hard to get you know all those
pieces right it's trying to figure out
what works best with our life right now
there you go so I would recommend
strongly and y'all y'all may do this
already I would recommend you and
Sam um by the way you said samurai and
that sounds kind of awesome just have to
shout out that um you and Sam once a
week I want youall to plan out not what
works indefinitely what works this
week I want to make sure you and Sam's
marriage is
Ironclad budget wise sexually conne
connection because managing all four
kids and doing something cool like
everybody gets to stay up a little later
we get to do tea parties we get do
something like this suddenly the
relationship that's going off the rails
as y'all
too there is some seasonality to this
and what I mean by seasonality is your
10-year-old is about to turn 11 12 and
13 and she's going to change
dramatically your eight-year-old is
going to move into middle school he's
going to change
dramatically like he's just going to
start turning fourth and fifth grade and
then suddenly sixth grade and there's
going to be a dramatic
shift you're six in and on down the line
so you're about to hit some major
Milestones here
one last thing with your eight and your
six-year-old that I would recommend I
think the 10year old everybody needs not
just a job but they need a role a
purpose a
gift they need to understand what they
bring to the
family and so that's not always fun and
there's a lot of hey to my son Hank go
back out and get the chickens or they
dogs have to eat and like oh geez dad
come on so it's not like it's perfect
every
time but my son knows he's got a very
particular not just chores but he's got
a a pillar that the house sits on my
daughter too and that's been tough
because it would be way way way faster
for my wife to cook dinner by
herself and when my daughter feels like
she's participating and making dinner
the whole experience is Magic there's no
yelling there's no screaming there's no
there's no none of the because she is
locked in relationally and locked in
with a
purpose so sit back with your husband
and say okay what's this week what
purpose can we give each one of these
kids this week when it comes to dinner
when it comes to this when it comes to
all right I'm going to be having to go
to work and so we're going to make sure
we wake up and have X and Y and Z maybe
we're going to hire a middle school kid
to come over and play with the
six-year-old and the three-year-old on
Saturday mornings with mom's at work
we're going to pay three bucks an hour
or whatever it is we're going to begin
to look at all the relational touch
points none of this is easy and every
kid is different um I have seen some
pretty remarkable stuff from parenting
expert and she goes by Dr Becky on
Instagram she has some really great
stuff um I haven't been through her
courses but it's got rave reviews um and
she has a particular um level of
expertise on something she calls a
deeply feeling kid that might be
something worth looking into um again
she goes by Dr Becky deeply feeling kids
um if you have an 8-year-old that just
feels like their body's electric on fire
some really good stuff there um but let
me be super
clear your kids aren't allowed to hit I
will remove you and yes there is a point
when I am bigger than you I will pick
you up and move you out of this
room and you have to be careful with a
deeply feeling kid or a kid that is is
wrestling with these wild emotions
because that in some ways gives them
exactly what they
want
connection time one-on-one attention
laser focus from Mom and
Dad so where can I give time and
attention and laser focus and
connectivity to that kid that is
positive in nature not responsive in
nature that's hard when you got four of
them running
around it's
hard and Sam I know as somebody who
struggles with this you walk home and
you are so overwhelmed being lasered in
all day you just want to go let's do
nothing doing nothing for a 10 an eight
and a six and a three-year-old is a
recipe for chaos it's pulling the fence
down and letting them just run a muck
and they go crazy and they trip and fall
hit their
heads so it's coming home and choosing
I'm going to laser back in also with
that 8-year-old um sometimes it's good
just hey we're going to go for a long
long
walk we're going to go to the creek
we're going to go go to the park we're
going to go do a thing do we have time
to do that no do we have stuff we got to
do at home yes and we're going to plug
in and it still doesn't mean we're not
going to have a fight at bedtime but
we're going to do this again and I'm
going to show up again and I'm going to
show up again what you're going to see
over time is the bed time stuff starts
to minimize the fights start to minimize
the chaos in the house slowly comes down
but here's the question Sam and Megan I
want youall to ask I want youall to ask
this
question every Sunday night
together
I want you to ask this question how can
I love you this week what do I need from
you this week how can we minimize chaos
in the house this
week just ask that question and see if
there's if there's money stress see if
there's relational stress see if there
is we need to put sex on the calendar
see if there is we need to go on a date
night see if there is what do we need to
do in this house we need to go exercise
what do we need to do in this house to
begin to minimize the chaos that the
kids might be touching the electric
fence and getting
burned
and don't fail to use the resources at
your local school you pay for them
you'll get them you're in it guys you're
in it that's a whole bunch of ideas
every kid's going to be
different make sure your kids know
they're connected make sure they know
they've got a part we'll be right
back hey deloney here and it's pumpkin
spice latte season just kidding that's
disgusting but it is fall it's a little
cooler the sun's going down down earlier
and God help us daylight savings time is
ending or starting or whatever the time
is the time is changing again and it can
be exhausting to adjust to everything
all the time so make sure you're moving
your body every day getting sunlight in
the morning and in the evening and
getting 7 to n hours of sleep each night
I can't stress enough how important this
is sleep is the Cornerstone to physical
physical and mental and emotional health
and for me great sleep starts with an
amazing mattress that's why I love
dreamcloud and why my family sleeps on
dreamcloud and right now dreamcloud is
running an awesome offer 40% off all
mattresses plus an additional $50 in
savings exclusively for our listeners go
to dreamcloud sleep.com and enter promo
code John deloney that's dreamcloud
sleep.com with code John deloney for 40%
off all mattresses and an extra $50 in
savings all right let's go out to Toledo
Ohio and talk to Mara Mary what's up
Mary hi what's
up uh nothing nuts I am really really
nervous I love your show though I do not
miss an episode so you're too excited
thank you so so much what's up um so my
question
is how do I communicate with my husband
without um him becoming quite defensive
we've only been married for about two
and a half years so still kind of new to
all of this but it's been pretty
prevalent since I'd say since we were
engaged um I feel like whenever I ask
him a question or just kind of having
difficult conversations it just kind of
goes over like a bag of bricks and I'm
not really sure
what I'm doing wrong or how I'm
contributing to it I've tried to ask
them in the moment and outside of those
heated moments how I could phrase my
questions to make them less offensive
but he has kind of told me that he
doesn't want to tell me how because it
that just feels weird to tell him to
tell me how to communicate with him um
the questions can range from finances
hold on hold on hold on hold on you are
being gaslit out of your mind my friend
oh let me be like super clear you can't
he is choosing to be
offended
period he's either choosing to be
offended by what you
say he's choosing to be offended by
going back in and back in and back into
the same
conversations and he's choosing to or
he's choosing to be offended by not
giving you Clues as to why what you say
hurts
him I kind of have I do have in like I
do know
why um he's got a lot of Shame from his
past he's got a lot of stuff that
happened when he was a kid that don't
care here's why me
too and my wife doesn't have to carry
that I
do like your job is not to tiptoe and
dance around him for the rest of your
marriage his job is he said I do he says
I love you till the end of
time I find it un I find myself unable
to have these hard conversations to you
based on childhood sexual abuse based on
being poor based on any number of things
that might have happened to him and it's
his responsibility to go get the help
and healing and care that he needs so he
can dial in to his wife that's his job
and he is doing that he's been going to
therapy for a few months now I think
okay probably almost half a year and it
has helped like good I I have seen
improvements he's not living in fight
ORF flight mode which I've told him you
know I've encouraged him from the
beginning when we were engaged I was
like you need to go deal with that stuff
because you deserve kind of like you
I've heard you say like you deserve to
be well it's not because you're
defective you just deserve that so I've
encouraged him and he he is doing that
he's doing the work and we're actually
going to go in together to talk to his
therapist about this because
perfect um yeah that's this week um so I
wrote this before we decided that but I
was like I just don't feel like we can
have this conversation we just can't
find a resolution and I I need a third
party or something because I just I
don't understand and it's just been hard
because every
time his default kind of is just the say
that I don't trust
him and unfortunately yes he has made a
couple of you know mistakes where the
trust was broken and it was it was awful
because he accused me of that before it
happened so when I found out and it's
just and that was just finan like a
financial thing it was misusing a credit
card that we both knew we were like we
were going to get one and I wanted to
talk about how to use it but he thought
that me asking like having that
conversation of what our expectations
were he thought that that was me not
trusting him and basically accusing him
of over spending and then that's kind of
what happened hold on hold
on hold on
Mary why didn't you look him in the eye
and say honey I don't trust
you because like after the fact when he
says oh you don't trust
me why don't you say I can't trust you
because I don't
know
it's like I feel like I you know we had
those conversations after all that
happened and I've really wanted you know
I've forgiven him hold on and it's not
just like sitting in the back of my head
I just don't no it's sitting in your
nervous
system it's a part of you
now and he won't take ownership of it
and Mary every time I try to point
something out that he needs to go do you
defend him and you protect
him what is it about what what is it
about why when did you have you had the
job of Peacekeeper your whole
life
no I don't think so my I I grew up with
really great parents and the
conversation was anything was on the
table like to this day like they're
still like they
they're just really easy to talk to and
I
don't that's why I've just been so
confused because I've you know I've done
the introspection like what is it like
is it me it's not am I something it's
not
you and it's almost like you you would
rather it be you because you don't want
to deal with the alternative that it's
him it's absolutely absurd that a
husband will not talk to his wife about
finances period
period it's absurd I would tell any
grown man on planet Earth
that you know why because I have held
wives whose husbands have died who look
me terrified in the eyes and say I don't
know where anything is and I don't know
what to do
next they don't know where the insurance
papers are don't know where the mortgage
pay they don't know who they don't even
know what a mortgage is they don't even
know what it
is it's
absurd anytime somebody in a marriage
says the words oh you don't trust me I
call bull crap on
that because I I feel like he doesn't
trust me like I guess with information
like knowing stuff does he know that
though have you been that honest with
him I I told him yes I said look this is
just an observation but I feel like you
don't want me and i' I've seen this with
other people but me too he doesn't want
me to know kind of like what he's got
going on in his head his plans when he's
going to do things why he's doing things
what it is because he doesn't want he he
he's afraid that maybe I'll try to like
control him or blackmail or judge him
and I know that yeah it's probably
coming from the shame based place but
it's not okay it's
it just you know what it is it's
infidelity it's
infidelity people get obsessive about
infidelity being about who had sex with
who I think Fidelity in marriage is way
bigger than that yeah it is somebody
going
elsewhere is what that is living an
alternative life a double
life a life separate from their person
that they said I
do
and I think there's you are
so I think you're such an introspective
person and you're such a kind person you
are doing everything you can to look in
the mirror and figure out what you have
done to deserve this and I'm telling you
third party nothing that you've told
me and where I think that is scarier for
you that means you have to drop your
shoulders and exhale and probably weep
pretty hard because your marriage isn't
what you thought it
was or your husband's not who you
thought he
was and that's terrifying
right
yeah like I said we you know he is very
wanting to very much wanting to work on
this so I don't feel like you know it's
a dead end and we're not gonna sure you
know get through it I just sure yeah
it's just a lot yeah it is a lot
especially for someone like you who has
seen the other side you've seen how
amazing it is when people are just open
and put everything on the table and talk
through things and disagree and fight
and laugh and carry on that's the home
you grow up in right yeah yeah you know
what the other side feels like and
you're watching somebody self- select
into
Suffocation and think they're winning
and you're like no I know what it's like
when everybody's just laughing and
breathing
yeah and so it's extra
hard some people when two people marry
each other and they both come from Abus
of households sometimes there's this
fantasy about what things could be like
it's not a fantasy to you you've lived
it yeah right and it's terrifying that
he won't participate in that to answer
your question whole you're doing the
exact right thing which is y'all are
going to a counselor together okay
here's what's going to going to be
underneath
that I want you to spend some time
between now and going to see that
counselor and if it's in a couple of
days amazing and I want you to spend
some direct
time and this is going to be scary
writing down what you want and what you
need and when you talk to him I don't
want you to use words with the counselor
because the counselor going to say what
would you like to say and I don't want
you to say things like well I feel that
you cuz the moment you do that he has to
go on the
defense
m i want you to have the courage and the
strength to look at your husband in a
safe therapist office and
say I have to know what's going on
financially in our
home I have to know what is in your mind
when it comes to planning thinking about
our future because this isn't just your
future this is our
future I want you to say honey I am so
scared I can't
breathe because I feel like I'm alone in
my own
house I sleep next to a man I love and I
feel completely
alone and when you do that what you're
doing is you were talking not about him
but about
you and he has to feel and learn the
impact his
choices have on his
wife not under
attack you say I feel dumb when you tell
me don't worry about
it I feel unsafe when I wake up every
day and I don't know where the insurance
papers are and I don't know how much
money we have in the account not how
much money you've
borrowed mhm see what I'm saying this
makes it all about
you and what you've been doing for the
last however many years is trying to
make it all about him and how you can
fix him you can't that's the scary part
and it sounds like he's making the
choices to do something different that's
[Music]
cool but just going to counseling isn't
going to help I mean it's it is going to
help but it's not enough he's gonna have
to start acting
differently
yeah and so how can you going back to
your original question how can you say
things in a way that won't be offensive
to
him he has to have the courage to tell
you here's what I need from you when we
talk and he can't say oh that's just too
weird okay then you are choosing
offence you know what I mean you're
choosing that yeah yeah it's it's like
people who watch Dave Chappelle stand
up either hey they watch it they they
they click on
it and they just sit there and get
offended the whole
time it's like you turned it on or two
yeah you don't email Dave Chappelle I
don't if he's got an email and say hey
when you say these three things it's
very very
hurtful yeah right then you're at least
saying it and then I'm out I'm not going
to keep clicking on that
M but I don't know what's going on in
your sweet husband's head but I need you
to know it's not your
fault it's not your
fault and I know that's scary but it's
not your
fault write down what you want write
down what you need and when you sit down
with the counselor and him make it about
what is happening to you
and it's going to feel like you're
attacking him you are not you are
telling him the
truth I'm
scared I feel
dumb I feel
unloved let's start there I'm proud of
you proud of you trying to figure out
every way you can possibly love this
man it's time for him to continue his
healing journey and he's got to start ch
changing the way he does things
hopefully you and him and this new
counselor find a path forward you
thinking about you guys be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feel feelings and be able to better
respond to whatever life throws at you
so you can build a more peaceful
nonanxious life get your copy today at
john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
from the great Melissa ethd the song is
come to my window it makes me think of
Come To Butthead remember that from me
Butthead used to always say that come
come to my window crawl inside wait by
the Light of the Moon come to my window
I'll be home
soon I would dial the numbers just to
listen to your breath
e and I would stand inside my hell and
hold the Hand of Death I don't know how
far I'd go to ease this precious ache
and you don't know how much I'd give or
how much I can take just to reach you
come to my window come to butt it crawl
inside wait by the Light of the Moon
come to my
window I'll be home
[Music]
soon love that song love you guys
bye